Yeah,
I don't think my wife loves are
internationally adopted daughter and she
won't go to counseling with me.
My house is filled with tyranny and
anger.
Any advice?
Anonymous.
Wow,
that's a loaded.
That's a set of loaded questions,
man.
I don't think my wife loves are
internationally adopted daughter.
Well,
the first question would be why not?
Was she in on the adoption,
for example,
was it partly her decision?
Here's a possibility.
Maybe you could ask her under what
conditions.
Ask her more specifically why she
doesn't like your internationally
adopted daughter.
It's too vague.
I don't think my wife loves are
internationally adopted daughter.
Break it down.
Maybe it's something like there are 15
things about our life with our
internationally adopted daughter that my
wife does not appreciate.
Now maybe some of those things are the
way that the daughter behaves.
I don't know how old she is or anything
else about her and
differentiate your problem.
It's too vague.
You'll never solve it this way because
love isn't the right word.
See if you can write down 30 reasons why
your wife is annoyed about your current
situation and maybe you'll have to
differentiate each of those 30 into 10
more,
right?
Maybe there's 300 reasons and then see
if you can start asking her about fixing
some of the reasons that you
differentiate it because obviously you
can't go up to her and say you have to
start loving are internationally adopted
daughter that's just not gonna work and
you already know that.
But if you break that down into the 20
reasons why she doesn't like your
daughter,
then maybe you can figure out a way that
some progress might be made on one of
those problems.
And maybe if you take that approach for
a whole year,
then she'll go from like,
she'll at least hit neutral or something
like that.
Um,
that's the best I can do given that I
only have three sentences to go on.
So differentiate the problem and then
solve the smaller problems.